et on évoque la communication des
manuels macro avec un spécialiste en
communication stéphane rozès politologue
enseignant à sciences po et à hec
bonsoir stéphane rozès merci de répondre
à une question sur arte france emmanuel
macron la vue donc très actif il se
soigne au niveau de sa maladie sont
également sa communication on l'a vu
durant ces sept jours instagram avec un
poste avec son chien des mots pour
appeler à ne pas abandonner les animaux
de compagnie alors que beaucoup de
chiens et chats vont être offerts à noël
un entretien à l'express en tant que
spécialiste de la communication
politique comment est ce que vous vous
analyser toutes ses récentes sorties
le pays dans l'instabilité sanitaires
économiques sociales face au terrorisme
et stabilité géopolitique attendent du
président une forme de cohérence qui
rassure et donc effectivement il est
nécessaire que le président communique
le sujet et est ce que les français
sentent la cohérence présidentielle et
là la réponse est sans doute nous pour
plusieurs raisons c'est que en france on
attend une vision 20 capes et une bonne
distance à l'égard des français que or
la communication ensemble brouillonne il
ya eu par exemple un interviewde en brut
qui ne semblait pas très structuré et
cohérent
vous avez parlé de la communication du
président contre l'abandon des animaux
de stick
vous avouerez c'est pas tout à fait à la
hauteur de ce que les français attendent
du président alors rien interview
important vous l'avez mentionné dans
l'express régulièrement le président
s'est exprimé pour donner le fond de sa
pensée a été pendant la présidentielle
le 1
une fois élu le point les lettres 16e
new york pour l'étrange et hélas en fin
d'année le président veut un peu retirée
analyse et son adresse aux français mais
il le fait comme un interprète un
commentateur des français il est dans la
représentation il n'est pas dans
l'incarnation n'attend pas d'un
président qui soit politologue
philosophe on demande qu'il incarne la
nation qu'il fasse bilan de son action
et 10 où il va et mon pack le renvoi aux
contradictions historique ans est une
barre responsabilité des difficultés du
pays donc ça c'est le premier problème
de forme sur le fond
souvent ces constats sont juste
intéressant en tout cas moi sur beaucoup
j'ai pu pouvait donner un état récemment
dans le monde se lève sur les principaux
éléments presque au terme près je peux
me retrouver
par contre les raisons alors souvent
sont esquivés où le président selon moi
je vais prendre un exemple il dit en
france et c'est important pour nos tests
étrangers il ya une centralité de bêta
et pourtant les françaises des heures à
l'égard de l'état mais il pas pourquoi
d'état juste il ya le retour du malheur
français après les mouvements sociaux
mais il n'explique pas pourquoi ni à
juste titre pour la france l'europe
c'est la france et ça peut être assez
long il ne va pas au fond des choses il
ne va pas suffisamment loin mais mais
pour aller un peu plus loin stéphane
rozès au delà de ces sept jours
d'isolement
il ya eu d'autres communications à au
delà même pendant le la période
duco vide ou même pendant également là
la période des attentats il ya eu brut
il ya eu ce match at il ya eu al jazeera
face aux jeunes face au monde musulman
dans le monde
ça suffit à redonner confiance aux
français de multiplier la parole comme
cela ma conviction est ce que j'essaie
de faire passer fait que le sujet n'est
pas est-ce que le président s'exprime
trop ou pas assez
mais est ce qu'il est cohérent or sur la
plupart des prêts de fonds misait pas il
revendique la république et il s'inscrit
dans le propos de jean pierre
chevènement mais il pense qu'il ya un
problème
ces deux hommes blancs une approche
américaine pense qu'il faut faire la
discrimination positive
cette approche américaine il propose
d'entités en faisant les décaissements
mémoire or le propre de la france ce
n'est pas de cette danse in pace ne tout
le contraire de définir un projet
politique pour l'avenir
la grande erreur de me koné 5 au 10
avait été de demander aux français
qu'est ce qui fait notre identité
lorsqu'il fait notre identité c'est
justement le fait qu'elle n'est pas
cynique et rené charles faisait le pôle
est notre héritage n'est précédé d'aucun
testament
donc ce que je suis en train de lire
article voit le prédit nice historique
qui ne sont pas censés mans klaus mais
il n'a pas le pompier cohérente entre le
diagnostic
ce qu'il faut faire ce qu'est la france
et son apport au monde le mag leur
présence des français qui fait le
déclassement économiques sociales et
politiques de la hante
et c'est fou albert en europe merci
stéphane rozès d'avoir répondu à nos
questions d' avoir décrypté la
communication de d'emmanuel mali très
bonnes fêtes de fin d'année à vous je
rappelle que vous êtes politologue
enseignant à
à sciences po et hec